are you okay
um
i'm pretty overwhelmed
like you don't have any doubts about
tomorrow like is there anything that
bothers you
if i wasn't gonna marry you if i wasn't
ready enough to marry i don't need 10
months i don't need 90 days
like we were together in china we
separated and as he came back for you
that should mean a lot
yeah
i mean it means a lot but
all these things are just coming out of
the woodwork and i'm like
where are they coming from
like
knowing that deep down you want to move
to ohio like i need to know these things
and i don't want to like find out
a year after marrying you
like what do you mean by is he finding
more about me
like do you feel like i'm here because
of a certain benefits or what
that's insulting
i've been waiting for a long time to get
to this point i mean the point where we
get married
yeah it's not been an easy journey
i mean i've tried everything
i can just to let her know that okay i'm
yours and i love you and i want you
but man
i'm not seeing myself thinking anymore
so there's something i want you to know
all right
i left everything back home in cameroon
to be here just so we can be happy
together
i've left friend family i fought to be
here and you still doubt me
kobe listen
how does that really happen
you're getting married to somebody you
don't fully trust that makes sense
i don't know what to say right now all
right
i don't know where to sit right now if
you can trust me at the eve of our
wedding
i cannot
accept that
ugh
[Music]
you